that's a b5 that's a sacrifice no no he
didn't drop anything
well
he must have missed b5 no you don't you
don't allow this rook takes c7 that
seems insane to me yeah but how do you
stop it how do you stop it because b5 is
really exorcism this is already serious
threat the position is not nice
uh
queen e6 b5 beautiful idea rookie for
trade rook c7
you just have no sort of counter play in
this position whatsoever
all right showing bishop takes f6 did we
oh white yeah we didn't show this check
no because this was brilliant bishop
takes f6 what a move the point here
being of course that if black decides to
take with the queen
uh instead of the pawn on f6 then there
would be queen tanks f6 g takes f6 and
the rook on d8 is hanging so therefore
he was forced to take with the pawn on
uh
on f6 here and after queen g4 there is
simply just uh no good move for uh
although it's not very clear to me
immediately because after king of fate i
do see that there is the bishop on b4 is
trapped so yes bangkok decided okay this
is this is enough this is enough because
there's literally no moves there's g5
threatening at some point for hikaru
this is a piece of cake technique
fantastic i mean what can i say he
clearly outlined his opponent based on
his understanding in opening